say stock XYZ is trading at $31 we have
a call option on stock XYZ with a $35
strike price it's trading at $8 we have
a put option on stock XYZ with a $35
strike prices have the same strike price
trading at $12 and they both have the
same expiration over here and then
finally there's a bond and this bond is
unrelated to stock XYZ it's going to be
a risk-free bond so it could be some
type of a Treasury bill worth $35 at
option expiration and you can buy it
right now for $30 and the reason where
you can buy it for less is you pay $30
you're going to get $35 in the future at
option expiration so you're essentially
getting interest on that bond so with
these numbers is there a way to make
risk-free money and to think about that
let's think about the the put-call
parity we learned that a stock plus a
put at a given strike price and the put
is a put on that stock is equal to it's
going to have the same value at
expiration as a call with the same
strike price a call with the same
underlying stock plus a bond a risk-free
bond that's going to be worth that
strike price at the expiration of these
two options so since these are going to
have since this is going to have the
same value the same payoff in any
circumstance as this at expiration they
really should be worth the same thing
but when you look at the numbers over
here let's see if that works out the
stock is trading at $31 so the stock is
31 the put option is trading at $12 so
that that's plus 12 so this on the
left-hand side right now if you had to
buy it it's trading at 43 it's trading
at $43 on the right hand side you have
the call option it's trading at $8 so
that's at $8 and then the bond is
trading at $30 the bond is trading at 30
so this combination is trading at $38 at
$38 so even though they have the exact
same payoff at option expiration at
in exploration the call plus the bond is
cheaper than the stock plus the put so
you have an arbitrage opportunity you
have an opportunity to make profit from
a discrepancy in price from two things
that are essentially equal and what you
always want to do is you always want to
buy the cheaper thing you always want to
buy the cheaper thing and you want to
sell the more expensive thing especially
when they are the same thing when
they're going to have the exact same
payoff in the future so you want to sell
this so buying is pretty straightforward
what does it mean to sell this over here
well you could short the stock so you
would short the stock you would short
the stock that's essentially you're
selling the stock and then you would you
essentially are shorting a put option or
another way to think it you could write
a put option so you would short the
stock plus plus right right a put and so
what would happen there shorting the
stock you're borrowing the stock and you
are selling it so you're going to get 31
you're going to get 31 dollars from
shorting the stock and writing the put
means you literally are essentially
creating a put option and then selling
it to someone else and so you're going
to get 12 dollars for that so you're
going to get your $43 and then you're
going to buy the call and the bond so
you're going to spend $8 on the call $30
on the bonds you're going to spend $38
so you're going to spend $38 and so
you're going to make a profit of $5 and
what we're going to see in the next
video is you make this profit upfront
and no matter what happens to the stock
price going forward you're able to
rearrange things so that you everything
else just cancels out and you can just
keep your $5